[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the experience as a teenager of being
part of a
group of young progressive evangelical
christians
uh in the late 60s and coming to read
theology
and then coming to read moral theology
and then
thinking these guys keep talking about
you know kant and
these other philosophers so maybe i
should read that i was also dealing with
coming to terms with my sexual
orientation and
wanting a framework that wasn't
the framework of a kind of uh moral
teaching that just told you what was
right and wrong but didn't say why
um and i wanted to think about why
things might be right and wrong in order
to decide whether certain things were
actually right or wrong
um but then you know as a profession so
that's
why i started reading philosophy really
and then
including moral philosophy though i
didn't just read moral philosophy i was
reading all kinds of philosophy
um and then another big impetus was
when i finished my phd which was not
about social political philosophy was
about philosophy of language
i got a job my first job as professor of
um assistant professor of uh
african-american and african studies and
philosophy and i wanted to teach
something in the second half of the job
the african and african-american
part of the job that was um useful to
the
that program and it seemed to me that
there were two things that were useful
one of them wasn't
social political philosophy it was just
sort of philosophy of social science and
philosophy of biology about the race
concept but the other was
ethics racism trying to understand
what racism is what's wrong about it and
so on
and so in order to do that having not
done a lot of work in graduate school
or even as an undergraduate really in
formal ethics i had to read
up and formal ethics and political
philosophy and social philosophy in
order to
to do that so two stages one is just
getting interested in philosophy
which had a lot to do with my sense of
who i was both as a young christian and
as a gay person
and then then when i came to um
my first job i i needed something to do
as it were
in that part of the job and that seemed
like and then and then i just got
interested and
then i was stuck
[Music]
well it wasn't when i started out i mean
there wasn't a lot of stuff
and that was part of the reason it was
interesting to me was because it's nice
to
work in fields which where there's just
lots of low-hanging fruit as it were
um so i started on work in philosophy of
race which is a
genre of identity uh because i was in
this department and it seemed like a
useful thing to do and there wasn't very
much
uh there's lots of sociology lots of
anthropology lots of
uh lots of work relevant work in biology
but not
much in philosophy at that point so i so
that was great
because as i say you could just start
thinking philosophically about something
there's material to work with but there
wasn't a lot of work but
by philosophers so you could sort of you
know make progress
pretty swiftly um on race and racism
and then it's natural for a philosopher
who's interested
in race to think well race because
philosophers generalize
race is a species of something what's
it's a species of but it's a species of
the genus
identity and
that was a particularly good time to
start thinking about that because
feminist
philosophy was really taking off and had
done a lot of work on
gender as a form of identity so bringing
together my own work on race which was
obviously influenced by the work on
gender because that was the one place
where there was
some decent stuff to work with with the
work on gender
you know you get a more generalized
notion and then
you know when i started thinking about
well why do these things matter
it struck me that actually identity is a
central
topic in ethics um we live our lives
ethics in aristotle's sense of um the
study of what it is to live well for a
human being and the good life
uh eudemonia and identity center central
to that because we live our lives
as uh ghanaians
americans uh gay people straight people
cis people trans people and what does
that mean
well that's that's what the ethics of
identity is about and i
read a book called the ethics of
identity it was about how
identity fits into ethical life and
again that was a somewhat neglected
topic um in um
people have thought about as we were our
identity as rational beings that's
central to kant's ethics
but the idea that our social identities
not the ones we all share but the ones
that divide us
are also important in ethics it's
obviously there in
in the political philosophy literature
on nationalism and so on
but not in a generalized way not
thinking generally about how identity
fittings
fits into ethical life and so that's i
don't mean to say there's nothing in the
history of philosophy of course that
would be absurd
but it wasn't really a feel the subfield
and so
it was again interesting and fun to
try to define a field in a certain sense
[Music]
so my first job as i said was at the
university of ghana and there
uh university education was a very rare
and pr special
and privileged there were not a lot of
opportunities to study anything
there were only three universities at
that point in ghana these were
people for who often came from families
where the very idea of a university was
a strange one
and they who their families didn't
really know as well what they were doing
they knew that they were very lucky
because they knew that people with
university educations were
tended to be better off but they
you know but they couldn't go they
couldn't go home to their families and
say oh i decided to study philosophy and
the parents would say oh yes that's
terrific
um far from it so so that was one thing
and then i taught a bit of cambridge
when i was a fellow of a college
and i wasn't teaching things in ethics
so the question of identity wasn't
a topic but of course it was very clear
to me
there were only three non-white people
in my college
class was just an overwhelmingly
determinative thing in people's lives
and the people i taught
even though the fact that i was not
white
shaped my contacts and my friendships
a little bit the real striking thing to
me was class and it was
and i i still think that that's one of
the great challenges of of
the universities in in britain and in
the united states it's a big challenge
here and
i wrote a chapter about class in my last
book and
universities play this incredible role
in solidifying class systems
and we really ought to be more reflexive
about it and and more
careful than we are but when i came to
united states
um the most important thing about me for
most people was that i was
not white black so identities you know
different identities
uh matter in different places i'd say
also that i probably that i was gay i
mean i think i think students
again the united states was behind
britain in terms of
the decline in homophobia so for some
gay students it was nice to have an
openly gay faculty
member
[Music]
so my first books were just aimed at
philosophers they were
they were called assertions and
conditionals and for truth in semantics
those are not the sort of books that
people rush into bookshops and
pull off the shelf because they think oh
that looks interesting but
once i started writing both essays and
articles and books that were addressed
to a wider
public um it became clear to me that
you don't really control what people
will do with your books you can't
you can't as well force them to read
them in any particular way so people
took up things that i'd said
in ways that surprised me and found them
useful in ways that i wouldn't have
predicted
and that's fine by me i mean reading a
book is a
is something of a commitment and i don't
you know
i think people should do with it
whatever they want and if they don't
want to do with it what i
would imagine they would do with it i'm
happy for them to do something else with
it so
um you know a lot of what's interesting
to me
in these books is is because i'm a
philosopher it's kind of the technical
structure of the ideas but that isn't
terribly interesting for most people
what's interesting is applying it and
and so increasingly
but always from the beginning really
when i was writing for the general
reader uh i i told stories i
gave examples of a sort of
practical sort of from my own life or
from novels i was reading
or or from history books what i came to
see
was that there's a kind of understanding
which comes from
uh explaining a concept narratively by
telling stories about how the concept
works
that is different from the kind of
understanding that philosophers
characteristically seek to communicate
which is kind of conceptual
understanding
propositional understanding telling you
truths as it were
um it's not that this isn't a way of
understanding truths it is
but it's it's a different way of
understanding this is one that
philosophers aren't
i would say usually terrifically good at
so i had to learn how to do it
um and maybe i'm lucky that my mother
was a novelist and so i grew up around
someone who was good at it but i'm
pleased when people say the book was
useful
then they tell me what they did with it
and i think oh sometimes i think oh
that's very interesting i would never
have thought of doing that
um and that's fine if i'm taken to have
said something that i really didn't
think i said then i write another book
or another article to
say to try and get clearer what i was
trying to say
and also i write on the same topic
sometimes because
i've learned from the response that i
got to the last time i
were around that i either didn't
understand something and that my readers
have helped me to understand it better
or didn't communicate something
and i tried to sort of restate the thing
in a way that
i think is more likely to be taken up
correctly
but you can't rule out uh
misunderstanding
and creative misunderstanding is one of
the ways that intellectual progress
happens
so i'm perfectly happy to be
misunderstood sometimes
[Music]
so let's take something in the lies that
mind which is a book about identity that
i wrote recently
relatively recently everything i have to
say in that book
about the role of nationalism
in people's political and psychological
and cultural lives
could have been stated in propositions i
could have just said
national identities operate to bring
people together so that they can
together run
societies and do their politics and
things like kind of said things like
that the way i did do it was
to tell the story of the way in which
the development of the italian nation
affected the life of vitalis
vevo the great italian mobilist and
i i think people get a better sense of
the way in which national identities get
a grip on you
by telling the story of this guy who was
born in the austro-hungarian empire and
ends up in italian
and not just an italian but one of the
great italian modernist
uh novelists even though he grew up
speaking german
you know uh i think that that tells you
you know you can draw many conclusions
from that one of course is is about the
sort of facticity of nations the fact
that the trieste is part of italy not
part of slovenia or not part of austria
it's all pretty contingent
talking about how in the novel he
expresses his love for his city
and that that's part of his attachment
to italy and so on i think those are
things that are
best told by telling a little bit of the
story of the life of
italos vevo i could say and it would be
true that
the modern concept of race is shaped in
the early 18th century in europe
but i told that story by telling the
story of a young boy
who came from what's now ghana to
germany
in the early 18th century and ended up
as the first
possessor of an uh european phd in
philosophy
uh by an african you know in the course
of his life
race is being made the modern notion of
resume and you can see it in the way his
life goes
and and one reason why at the end of his
life he returns
to ghana having lived all his childhood
all his late childhood and adult life as
a german
it was the rise of a kind of anti
a kind of anti-black
sentiment that made him more comfortable
back in this place that he barely knew
and so anyway these stories
communicate these abstract ideas and
they also
then you can you can make the abstract
point and people remember it because
they remember anton wilhelma
and so in that way telling his story
uh is is holding
as it gives people an anchor as it were
for their conceptual understanding of
the points you're making
so i'm working on two things now one is
a book about the idea of religion which
i think is a very misunderstood notion
i was raised atheist and as i mentioned
earlier i was an evangelical christian
as a child
and a teenager but um
but i think i but perhaps because of
that i find religion
deeply deeply fascinating and
increasingly
um i've expanded my interest to
religions other than the one that i grew
up with in the second project is a
project on
another idea that philosophers have
recently begun to say a lot more about
but
again when i started doing this it was a
somewhat
sparsely populated field which is
what work is in the sense of a job
and how that fits into ethics how do our
jobs fit into who we are
what it is to live well what it is for a
society to function properly
the rise of robots and all of that and
these are very important practical
questions in
in policy and sociology and economics
but
but the normative question uh if you
as as work changes uh
uh what does that mean for the
possibilities of a good life
these sorts of questions are not just
they're they're very important
sociological economic
issues but there are also these
normative questions about these ethical
questions how does
how does work reconfigured in that way
fit into a decent human life a life
worth living
so so those are the things i'm
beginning to think about so it's ethics
uh it's um i don't really like the term
it's applied ethics i think all ethics
is blind ethics but
but it's it's thinking about some
important
aspect of our lives in terms of the
question
how do we do this right and one of the
important points in this area i think is
that um
is that one way one constraint on doing
it right is recognizing
that doing it right is very different
for different people people are
different
and and one of the dimensions of their
difference to stick to my
old hobby horse is identity
you know one one thing the work used to
provide was a kind of class identity
which was a positive an important thing
and one of the things that my neighbor
um
my my working class neighbor in college
had to worry about was being alienated
from his working-class family by
becoming what he was going to become a
doctor a middle-class
person with a with a different style of
life from them and
and of course they were worried about it
too they were worried about losing
losing him in a certain way and that
that sort of question
now i know i know i don't think we
should live in that kind of class
society myself
so i'm against those those sorts of
divisions but i'm not against the idea
that you should take pride in
what you do and if what you do is
produce things
like cars or coal i think you should be
able to take
pride in that and if you can't we
shouldn't you know we should
let machines do it for more debates
talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas
at iai tv
[Music]